après plusieurs mois plongé dans
l'inconnu les représentants syndicaux
d'edf ont enfin reçu des détails écrit
de la part du gouvernement concernant le
fameux plan hercules visant à
réorganiser l'entreprise
un document de trois pages publié par
nos confrères de mediapart dans lequel
bercy expose ses choix partant du
postulat qu edf n'est plus en mesure de
financer son développement
le gouvernement souhaite donc
réorganiser l'entreprise en trois pôles
deux entités 100% public qui détiendrait
80% de la production d'électricité en
france avec notamment une filiale dédiée
barrage mais le point de discorde
concerne la troisième entité dans le
document elle est présentée comme suit
une filiale contrôlée très
majoritairement par edf et qui sera
consacré principalement au développement
des activités renouvelables et aux
réseaux de distribution
le gouvernement affirme aussi que des
garanties légales seraient donnés sur le
maintien de cette filiale dans le
secteur public pour le reste le document
entretient le flou seule certitude le
nom hercules initialement donné au
projet est abandonné les salariés auront
le luxe de lui trouver un autre nom
malgré les promesses du pdg d'edf
estimant qu'il n'y aura ni scission ni
privatisation
l'entrée de fonds privés au capital
d'une partie de l'entreprise provoque la
réticence d'un large front syndical
mobilisés depuis des mois des salariés
de l'entreprise font part de leurs
craintes
voici quelques-uns de leurs arguments
recueilli ces dernières semaines et
demain cette transformation cette
ouverture de capital sera que
mécaniquement une grosse partie de
l'argent reçu
en termes de résultats des entreprises
partiront dans les mains du privé donc
il faudra les compensées et notamment le
compenser des investissements et à tous
les besoins par des augmentations
taristas c'est une évidence pour tout le
monde et recule c'est prendre de
l'argent qui est produit par une
entreprise qui appartient à tous pour
donner les bénéfices qui sont dégagées
où les liquidités qui sont dégagées
uniquement à quelques-uns au projet
recul c'est le démantèlement d'edf
le démantèlement du service public tout
simplement donc demain c'est quoi c'est
une hausse des prix une précarité
énergétique encore plus importante
et cette notion de service public qui
pourrait ne plus exister
le document envoyé par bercy ne semble
pas destiné à calmer les ardeurs des
syndicats puisque aucune concession
concrète ni apparaît de plus beaucoup
s'inquiètent en réalité du débat en
cours avec la commission européenne car
c'est depuis bruxelles que se joue le
sort de df la réorganisation lancé par
le gouvernement est dans les faits un
moyen de se conformer aux règles de
concurrence imposée par l'union
européenne qui régule les tarifs et qui
oblige edf à vendre à ses concurrents à
prix fixe une part de l'électricité
produite par ses centrales nucléaires
et si les syndicats souhaitent aussi
s'extirper des obligations de bruxelles
ils ne soutiennent pas pour autant la
méthode employée par le gouvernement
l'entrée d'investisseurs privés dans le
secteur de la vente d'électricité
pourrait avoir des conséquences sur
l'emploi sur la souveraineté énergétique
et au final pour les consommateurs les
syndicats peuvent compter sur le soutien
de certains partis politiques de gauche
qui ont fait part de leur volonté de
lancer un référendum d'initiative
partagée sur cette question mais face au
rythme soutenu que semble vouloir
imposer le gouvernement les opposants au
projet font face à une tâche difficile
que l'on pourrait assimiler aux douze
travaux d'hercule